one of the 50 voters coming out and  saying yesterday quote i don't think you  can be the biggest jerk in the league  and punish your team and your  organization and your fan base the way  he did and be the mvp i think he's a bad  guy and i don't think a bad guy can be  the mvp at the same time  i think he's a bum i think he's an  absolute bum  you didn't know me i don't know who he  is no one knew who he was probably until  yesterday's comments but  i mean to and i listen to the comments  but to say  he had his mind made up in the  summertime  [Music]  in the off season that you know i had  zero chance of winning the vp  in my opinion should exclude  you know  future  future votes  um you know his problem isn't with me  being a bad guy or  the biggest jerk in the league  because he didn't know me he didn't know  he doesn't know anything about me i mean  i've never met him i've never had lunch  with him i've never had an interview  with him  um his problem is i'm not vaccinated